In this video, I want to briefly cover
a new experimental feature within Unreal Engine that
is the day sequence.
So let's jump over to the editor and take a look.
So I'm going to start with the litatmos in class map
within our content maps folder.
Now, if you've been following along
with previous videos and you still
have your old lighting or the lighting
that we created in previous videos,
go ahead and just delete all those actors.
And we can keep our post-processing volume.
That's absolutely fine.
So we shouldn't have any other lighting
except our small accent lights.
The rest of all of our day and atmosphere components
should be completely gone.
So I'm going to go over to our place actors.
And I'm just going to type in sun.
And I'm going to look for sun moon.
Let's go ahead and drag this into our scene.
And you'll notice that we already
start to get some lighting within here.
So let me just cover real quick what this is.
So the sun moon day sequence actor
is a component that's built on essentially blueprints
and some code with all of the various different components
that we've seen before when we were lighting
our scene from scratch.
So here we have our directional light.
Now, in this case, we have one for our sun
and one for our moon.
Our exponential height fog, sky atmosphere,
our sky light, volumetric clouds,
and then a sky sphere for projecting on the back.
All of these are controlled through various different route
components and the blueprint logic
that will allow us to essentially mimic
an actual time of day.
Now, real quick, what I'm going to do
is I'm actually going to rotate this 75 degrees, which
should allow us to get some light kind of going in here.
And you can see that I can adjust my daytime preview.
I'm just going to scrub this real quick.
Now, one quick caveat why I rotated this 75 degrees.
So typically speaking, if you were using this in production,
now another caveat, I would not recommend
using this in production because this is still experimental.
But if you had this in your scene,
ideally you would have your scene oriented with essentially
would be x forward, would kind of be your main direction.
But because this particular, our assets that are built here
are rotated and I want to get the light going through here,
I've just simply rotated the whole actor
by 75 degrees, which allows me to get some light there.
So that's the only reason why I did that.
It doesn't have to do with anything else.
All right, so at the heart of this actor
is this time of day.
So you can see as I scrub this, so I can just kind of drag
this little preview here, you'll
notice that it's essentially based off of a 24-hour clock.
And what this is doing is this is just dynamically
adjusting our light, so all those components,
as if we were doing it manually,
well, we can run this over and over again.
Now, hopefully this will work.
But if you press Play, this should start ticking
and it should work.
You may notice, you may not see it updating.
But this is essentially running a full time of day cycle.
Let me go ahead and pause it.
So what I want to show is a couple other different features
that actually make this work.
But what I want to do first is just
update or change one of these properties
so that this time of day updates a lot faster.
So I would do that through our, it should be, I believe,
our time of day, time per cycle.
And this is basically saying, how long
is it going to take in actual units
for a full time of day cycle to complete?
So right now, it's set at five minutes.
So going from 0, 100 hours all the way through to 0,
100 hours again is going to take five minutes.
So if I adjust this down to say something like 30 seconds,
should be fast, hit Enter, hit Tab.
If I press Play, again, this is a little bug
that I've noticed right now.
Again, fully experimental, that it still
is updating at our same interval.
So to change that, all I'm going to do
is just go up to our Play settings here.
And instead of selected viewport,
I'm just going to do Simulate.
So if I do Simulate, we should see it.
And there we go.
Now it's, again, rotating as fast as I want.
30 seconds to go through a full time of day cycle.
Let's just play for a second so you can see it.
And one of the other components here is our moon.
So now we're kind of at nighttime.
If I zoom up here, you'll see that we do have our stars.
And in this case, I think it should loop back on us.
We'll see here, it may just be fixed.
But that is one of the other advantages of using this.
I'm going to hit stuff.
Oh, that actually is still going.
There we go.
So you can see that this will just
need to loop over and over again
to have a real time time of day, which is a great feature.
Highly requested for many, many, many engine versions.
All right.
One of the other major components
of this actual system is this day sequence collection.
Now you can add the sequence to this.
But by default, it adds this DSCA 24 hour.
And you could browse to this, or we can just
simply double click this little icon and open it up.
This is where, if you are considering
using this in your project, this
is where you're probably going to make a lot of key
changes.
So in particular, we have the sequence.
So if I just open this up, this is a movie sequence.
And you see that it does target
a couple of different properties.
So our sky, sphere, volumetric cloud,
and then some of the properties through here.
So things such as sun intensity, moon size,
stars intensity, you can adjust that here in the sequence.
Let me close the sequencer.
The other thing that we have here is this sun position
sequence within the procedural sequences.
Now this is probably the most important one.
So if you're familiar with long lat, so longitude,
latitude, and time zones, this
is where you can essentially mimic
how the sun and the moon would interact based off
of a physical location.
So in this case, we're negative 5 GMT, latitude
and longitude.
You can enable daylight savings time.
And all this is going to do is just simply give you
a more realistic or real world based type of system.
So again, you could just type in real quick to Google Maps,
find a location, find the long lat, plug those in.
And as your day sequence run, it's
going to look more natural like that actual location.
So again, this is located within the day sequence collection.
If you expand it out and just double click this,
that will open those settings.
Now I would recommend if we just quickly browse to it,
you'll see here it's actually in the engine content.
Copy this DSCA 24 hours, this day sequence collection,
put it in your local project folder,
and rename it to something else.
That way you can keep the original engine version
and you have your own that you could add to your project.
So again, that's a really cool feature
that's in there called the sun, moon, day sequence actor.
But again, caveat, it is still experimental.
So use at your own risk.
But it is a great new feature making its way into the engine.
In the next video, we'll discuss the new MegaLights
feature included in Unreal Engine.